what is happening though reject a nation
smile for a camera
spider-man homecoming Ned's turn
you've heard of Ned Ned he's his friend
right yeah never seen a narc
he at Johnny's it's Filipino friend
that's right the character I'm most
looking forward to
Filipino just locked and whoa oh no
that's what you are and you're
ethnically ambiguous like cliff Curtin I
mean I'm Mexican person I'm Iraqi I'm
Mallory I'm a Salvadoran
all of the above Davo be stopped
Marilyn considered no no Eagle air
google it dude
the gang with the alien guns run by guy
with wings yeah they have a lair yeah
how are you look at the percent 300
miles on it whether you fought for wonky
prosecutor yeah I was hoping maybe I
could rejoin no no buddy you can't just
quit on a stroll up and be welcomed back
by everyone top Spurs ultimate what do
you think okay can we go already cuz I
was hoping to getting some light
protections and when the embassies over
again protesting is patriotic let's get
on the bus that skillful little boy yeah
Mario
a lot more stuff this is another trailer
that's what they do more trailers more
tree there's about spider-man and
releasing tons of footage I don't know
well the early reactions have come out
for this and it looks like everyone's
really liking it a lot most people are
saying that and willing to be Ani who
MIBs season he was eyeing that it's that
play the third best at least okay you
know take it back kind of like I using
covenant the third man okay and then
that guy who is called Ned sterner you
don't really see anything about him here
yeah wasn't to get much information his
turn to try the Matt why had several
requests for check this out he was
wearing the mask and not Peter yeah
crazy one thing that people were really
talking about the early reactions
without house capitalizing on the high
school experience the high school life
and him going to an academic decathlon
that is a very high school thing to do
definitely I did one I did not I was
home-schooled Helia how are decathlon's
were very different non competitive
non-competitive one just me versus
myself and who's the actor playing Flash
Thompson
Tony River Laurie from from the grand
Budapest hotel yes it was dope yes
that's his name I somehow twice on movie
fights
fantastically having you won both times
he was on actually pseudo he's been
really good he's really good his
personality their really won me over and
I'm excited for him to play the douche
bag Flash Thompson more technically
ambiguous Flash Thompson yeah yeah Tony
rebel or each time you go from Joe manga
lino
to kill werewolves yeah to a lull people
and good lobby boy yeah very drastically
different change but I'm excited for us
but we got our tickets already guys yeah
we are slated to watch it if you guys
live in LA we're going to the Cinemark
in North Hollywood at 10:00 p.m.
come say hi come find us and touch up
come say I'll definitely be wearing my
DC shirt just to upset everyone in the
audience and I will be naked which will
make everyone happy can Spiderman body
pain
going all out man you're gonna shoot
some web here definitely at the end of
the movie right during the climax
because out of wood why okay we got it
well now we're talkin Terry maybe Nate
here Balu I think it's how many people
requested I hope that Peter wins the
dekappa today I'm really going to take
one I hope he earns respect of his
teachers bring a friend's old and a half
hour devoted I don't want it to be like
oh he's up in Decathlon something starts
going wrong and then he has to be
spider-man and he has to help back
himself in my mission account I don't
want any of that he's got to answer a
few questions and then go out and save
that bow on him to just have a good time
put the decathlon and when and then
continue your spider-man yeah and maybe
go with his friends at protests make
this a Peter Parker story all of you
yeah only Peter we know what we would
want this that's why it's called meds
turn because Peter is going to get like
the twist as Peters gonna go yeah he's
going to do the cap on it and Ned's
going to do the suit and become
spider-man and the suits gonna make him
buck yeah cool
I also heard this one as the funniest
one so a lot of people are saying this
will be a really funny a man they got yo
coil so it must be my must be funny
looks like you're doing exactly what he
always does no yeah calm belly
yeah there's deadpan and deadpan and
does he hear about anyone
totally no scribe or reject click Bell
for notifications John that John
Humphrey Twitter Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and also check out
our patreon yada yada yada